we appear to be good excellent thanks
feel free to go eat welcome to the
meeting mr. Perry thank you everybody
for being here today
open the meeting with apologies
we have councillor Niki Davis and
councillor Abel Kramer can I have a
mover Thank You councillor Ludlow and
welcome to the committee goodbye Mia
Tong we'll move on to the minutes of the
meeting held 1920 an accurate reflection
or any comments that received the
minutes thank you mutant in seconded by
councillor Bolger and we move into the
covert 19 response for solid waste
services and I assumed that Jane will
take us through that report everyone has
read it outlining the response in
particular I'd like to note that it has
he wasn't there that we would like to
thank a b-line bond contracts in South
and disability enterprises through this
time and the other south and commercial
waste operators that have continued to
operate well through this for our
community throughout all the alert
levels to point that out publicly but
Jane would you like to comment on report
what I'd like to see and probably on
behalf of Matt and I who both have our
name to this report is that that was a
snapshot then in actual
thank Donna and Ian are probably far
better prepared or equipped to not only
answer Nene we can answer questions on
this report but provide a wee bit of an
update I don't know what you think Matt
but I think they would rather than me
just going through something which is
everybody's read and it's actually
history no although it sets the scene I
think for what's happening perhaps that
might be a more efficient way of
bringing the waste advisory group up to
speed thank you Thank You Jane so yes so
we're heading in to level 2 tomorrow and
so we've been fortunate that waste is an
essential service so we've been
operating right through all of the
levels at different extents obviously
level 4 was the hardest where we closed
all of the transfer stations with the
exception of a few to allow commercial
operators to still be servicing the
essential services such as the hospitals
and pharmacies and supermarkets
level 3 Saurus opening out to transfer
stations and the new safety protocols
and restricted hours and bringing the
public in the first number of days at
those sites were quite full-on and we
appreciate the extra efforts from the
gore district council with more staff at
their facility in extra staff from bond
contracts to make sure that the wait
times for the public were not too much
and we'd also like to thank the public
for their patience I understand that the
Invercargill transfer station had a good
air and air and a half queues at some
point over those initial first four days
with level 2 we're seeing the transfer
stations moving to the air normal
operating hours and the only things that
are going to be remaining closed will be
the matter escape in sight and the
Invercargill recycling drop-off center
everything else will be scheduled to
open curbside recycling collections have
been continuing as per normal with the
exception that from the 25th of March to
the 10th of May the recycling had to go
to landfill as it wasn't we weren't able
to process it under those levels four
and three
and it wasn't safe to stockpile the
product either we just couldn't cope
with that capacity of stockpiling if we
were operating now in did you have
anything else that we we've missed off
on that yeah as of monday certain
enterprises have been receiving
recycling again one of the comments from
him ish was that the quality of the
recyclables is almost pristine coming in
from some of the some of the collection
rooms which is quite the opposite of
what we were expecting I think that's
very positive here I think again the the
messages got out we're around about the
swapping back to the manual sorting
again and hopefully that has fed through
and that's great news I was tentatively
nervous about reverting back to bylaw or
solid waste boil or having that
reinstated and no longer accepting the
green waste in there in particular
councillor Ludlow thanks Alex look I
think the messaging the waste net were
putting out reminding people that the
recyclables were being handled by people
st ste was was really useful even though
we've known that for a while it's one of
those things that people need to be
reminded of frequently I guess you know
anecdotally maybe the other reason is
I've had more time to go and rinse their
recyclables but there was there was I
know from a media perspective there was
really good clear messaging that came
out as well so hopefully that's playing
apartment and a good outcome thank you
anybody else have any questions or
comments around the report no well thank
you very much for giving us the update
you know have a move for the report to
be received Thank You councillor loud
low and to Sikandar Thank You Mia Tong
all those in favor I'm seeing some nods
and some hands so and we're going to
assume that there was then carried thank
you and next time I'll put a motion can
we just have a bit more of an obvious
wave from from those on the committee
just so that we can make sure that that
I am getting everybody next we'll move
on to the waste plan review update the
recommendation here is that the report
be received but I'm sure that someone
will want to give us a little bit of an
overview but they'd like to take
themselves off a mute - yeah Thank You
Jane maybe I'd like to draw attention to
and I'm just getting it up in my screen
so apologies for a wee bit of a delay
yeah the what I'd like to draw your
attention to is the fact that we we
didn't get a payment for the West lady
and we have covered that in here and
included a letter we got we spent and
the we was at Claire's level talking to
her same level and MFE really put in our
case that we had kept him if he abreast
of how we were progressing the the
review here and we thought it was very
unjust that suddenly they wouldn't pay
to date we've had no response
and I I recall briefing our counselors
in an informal session that we probably
shouldn't hold out her hopes but I think
this could committee should be aware of
what has happened how we're dealing with
it and just re-emphasize until the
committee that we do have plans underway
to get this waste assessment done and
we'll certainly not be putting our next
payment at risk and I think other than
that unless either met or some of the
Ian's or Donna have anything to add we
should possibly take questions mr. Perry
you starting just report further to the
discussions that clear head Lee and Jane
head with the Ministry of Environment I
also had similar discussions post clear
and James discussions with the same
person and they were down on the the
emails that in if he had seen two
invitado city council staff where he was
a clear and teaching about timetabling
at no time that the MFE person alert us
to an impending legislative obligation
breach and on their basis I we are left
with the Deputy Secretary there you
should consider an its crash a payment
of 50 percent recognizing that there may
be there obviously is some
responsibility for us but they
in this donkey deep in tears of failing
to alert us to the deadline when were
timetabling with him and they gave the
Tessa blessing as to what we were doing
so I've lived it with him for his
consideration and I don't think we
should let this lie idle because you
know they have a duty of good faith to
alert us to any course of action that
may involve not meeting our statute
applications and they didn't do so
you're quite right there they've
certainly just left us in the lurch any
other me through the comments or
questions I think yeah Mr Perry's summed
it up pretty well and then thank you too
this is early for following this three
two it's it's all in black and white
it's been well recorded keep at it
thank you very much okay with that
closing comment received thank you
meeting all those in favor my favor
sorry present it thank you
it's unanimous and carried moving on to
standardizing curbside collection
support this is your report the
recommendation is that the report be
received as well would you like to give
us a bit of background on this
particular item you know thank you madam
chair so the report is really just
outlining work that has been underway
around the development of a series of
standardization of recycling in curbside
collection and that's both in terms of
what can can't be put into the
collection as well as how those
materials should be presented the
project itself is driven by the ministry
MFA who have engaged the
best management Institute in New Zealand
to actually undertake the research so as
the report indicates it's a four stage
project the first stage being basically
industry review into best practice what
happens across in other countries
nationally and internationally the
second stage involves a series of
engagement through 11 national Hui as a
report indicates the Otago Southland
here he was held about two weeks ago now
in was attendance from Thiele is well
the major contractors within the
management sector that included
representatives from bond disability
enterprises and the Hui also included
and was led by representatives from West
mins and from the ministry so the report
they also presented the findings from a
project team was looking at what
basically they saw was best practice
around what can be recycled I'm her that
she be presented as I say um largely
because different authorities are
accepting different products and under
different conditions so some authorities
accept squash plastic bottles others
accept whole plastic bottles some debate
around about having lids and bottles as
opposed to ladies elf bottles because
it's a different grade of plastic and as
a potential to contaminate the stream so
[Music]
indicates the the proposed products to
be accepted and the nature and the where
they should be presented so common
themes the came out of the day were
forbidden to be it around abide
commingled West the advantages and
disadvantages of that service know what
common theme was came back around the
general consensus was that moving
forward removal from removal of glass
from the waste stream is probably no
considered best practice I'm certainly
that's the preference of the MuRF
operators and if you look at the Murph's
closest to the next closest mercy in
Queenstown and Invercargill way all
operate glass art operations so very
interesting what's likely to I've seen
noted here with that they proposed
collection method could be up to five
bends what's likely to happen the year
like a few standardizing out throughout
the country would in we've got five
different bins who will be responsible
for rolling those bins out well that
mean that we have to change all of the
collection services throughout the
country what does it mean for us
regionally at this stage of Germany's
aruna guidelines I don't know that
there's any going there's got to be any
push to Monday up to that change yeah
certainly from certain point of view the
report notes again the practicalities of
having that number of separate
containers yeah may just may not be
practical
there was other debate as well around
about issues about the collection and
sorting of the Murph as opposed to
sorting at the
absurd where the general consensus that
amongst certainly the contractors that
some of the health and safety
implications of curbside sorting would
probably outweigh any benefit a really
good example is the curbside sorting in
rural areas on stretches of hundred
kilometer per hour roads which would
prove to be rather difficult yeah so
those are some of the common things that
came out as I said the report indicates
a timeline to 30th of June to present a
final report after which time I think we
will have to an opportunity to consider
that report and consider any changes to
levels of service that may arise as we
as we move forward knowing that anything
that we do in terms of changing our
current levels of service is likely to
require further consultation sure thanks
for bringing us to our team Jen that's
it's good to say that this is happening
initially councillor Ludlow did you have
a question no did anyone else have any
other questions or comments then can I
have a move that this report be received
please Thank You counselor Ludlow and
Sikandar I'm gonna pick on people I
think you counsel Bulger all those in
favor raise your right hand carried
thank you and that is the end of our
public meeting
can I have a mover that we may go into
public excluded yeah thank you meeting
and seeking goodbye cancel Bulger all
those in favor raise your right hand
thank you we will have a small